this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app you
already know the cash app is the number
one app and Finance but did you realize
you can get the most powerful debit card
in the world with the cash apps cash
card just select a boost in your cash
app swipe the cash card and save 10% or
more at Whole Foods Shake Shack chipotle
taco bell chick-fil-a and all coffee
shops around the country so we're gonna
talk about this a little bit more later
on the show to get you all briefed on
the cash shop and begin now how great it
is
but right now download the cash app for
free on the App Store or Google Play
market real good calm you guys what's up
babies far and wide
[Music]
all around the world do you hear
something different on in the studio
yeah you do it sounds a little bit
better and there's no more echoes
because we got this soundproof the [ __ ]
up dude we got one two three four five
six seven eight no wait one two three
four five six seven eight nine [ __ ]
nine ten ten we got ten actually know
what close that that bathroom door
probably even better we got 10 [ __ ]
blocks sound blocks or whatever the [ __ ]
they're called and it is on dude and it
sounds so good and I feel better I
didn't feel good doing it giving you
guys the you know I had to move studios
and I had to make it a little bit nicer
and the studio is great now but it for a
little bit it suffered but you know what
growing pains
right this cult is about growing pains
those dent shirts flew man every time I
restock them they're gone in a day these
[ __ ] things you're helping us back up
the [ __ ] Brinks truck for real
now I'm talking about
you are [ __ ] but it's they go they go
and I see him at your shows I see him
front row there's always somebody in the
front row with the [ __ ] wouldn't make
a [ __ ] dent shirts and and they're
they're really they're it's awesome dude
it's just cool cuz then I know you're a
cult member and we're gonna [ __ ] you
head to the log cabin at some point but
and and I don't know but uh how we doing
huh you know how are we doing we're live
on my app you can get the app if you
want Chris D'Elia type that in and you
can see the the podcast before anybody
and hear it before anybody but also uh
it's new years and it's been new year
it's been the new year for a week or so
- and how are the new year's resolutions
coming now I I don't do no New Year's
resolutions what's more annoying than
someone saying they're doing a New
Year's resolution someone who says I
don't do New Year's resolutions I don't
believe in them that always that always
drives me kind of nuts when somebody's
like you know what I don't believe in it
people say stuff like I don't believe in
marriage and I always want to be like
what do you mean it's right there people
get married you can see married couples
all the time saying you don't believe in
it is the wrong way to say things and I
always thought that ever since I was a
little kid you know what I don't believe
in eating meat oh yeah you don't believe
in eating meat oh yeah
chomp-chomp I just ate meat man right in
front of your [ __ ] face right in
front of your unconfined you don't
believe in it well what the [ __ ] man you
can see it you know what you can't see
Jesus Christ so let's do this
don't believe in Jesus Christ if you say
you don't believe in marriage or eating
meat cuz ones right in front yeah the
ones not I get it you have faith all
good cool very cool uh you know what
i-i've been thinking about also is like
the celebrities that uh but wait before
I even get into that how are your new
year's resolutions happening how are
they holding up cuz right now the second
weekend is when you start [ __ ] up
right when the gym starts to get a
little bit empty when people start
eating a little bit more sweets you know
I was talking to my friend Craig who
opens from
sometimes he's a really funny comedian
Craig Conant and and and he sounds like
this but he's always used to work at
Trader Joe's until he got fired because
he [ __ ] Instagram storied farting on
customers uh hey you're in your 30s
I believe in farting on customers that's
for sure so he got fired for farting on
customers told him not to do it did it
got fired hat so anyway
but imagine that she's like yeah oh you
got these oh cool oh you got these
pretzels okay you got these organic
shits OOP oh cool hey one more thing
have a nice day hey one more thing come
here closer have a nice day look thanks
for coming in Trainor Jones
take care mm-hmm anyway uh Wow I got so
lost there I didn't even know what the
[ __ ] I was talking about anymore oh he
said that people will come in on January
first he would always say and January
first he would always say people would
you'd always see people at the gym cause
it was like across the street from the
gym and he would always see people at
the gym and when it was like such a
[ __ ] crazy time of year because like
it would be so traffic he and all that
[ __ ] and then he said all of the food
like the vegetables and everything like
that and all the good stuff that's for
you he would sell so much more in the
first week of January and then the
second week in January
everyone would start [ __ ] buying
things that give you cancer again hey so
I do it that's what he said
I got Boulder coming up I have Colorado
Springs coming up and all the Utah shows
are all sold out it's the only time I'm
really doing a club on this tour I think
is do I'm doing it in Utah and I love
Utah man every time I go to Utah I'm
there at the gay pride the pride march
which is cool because you wouldn't think
of Utah or you wouldn't think of like
Salt Lake City is having a large gay
community because it's so well Mormon
and but it does and it's always cool to
see I love I like that I like when gays
are proud which is why I didn't even
realize but I'm drinking out of my cup
that says the gayest and I'm drinking my
iced americano out of that [ __ ] my
friend Mike got me shout out to Mike
Scharf so what was I saying about yeah
so I'm excited about my shows I was
talking about loose ends and I was
talking about celebrities that are still
religious which are pretty celebrities
that shout out look I if you know me I
like guys and girls that are passionate
about something I don't even give a [ __ ]
about what it is even if it's like it's
[ __ ] I don't care about like building a
couch if some guys just like loves
building a couch I'll sit and listen to
that guy talk about building a couch all
day long
so I like when people are really
religious and they talk about it and
they feel it I love to see that passion
you know I'm not religious myself but uh
it's uh it's uh it always makes me feel
good when I see someone so happy about
something now yeah I don't like it when
they [ __ ] push their beliefs on you
obviously that's annoying as [ __ ] but
people are saying uh people are always
like well how do religious people always
have to push their beliefs on me
why do religious people always have to
like why can't they just be religious
why do they always have to like push in
our faces but I see a lot of like people
who aren't religious always are like
talking [ __ ] about that and they're
always like pushing that on other people
just as much by the way which they don't
get that rap for they don't they don't
get that rap it's always the religious
people who are like oh you know who are
good to get the rap on pushing their
agenda on you but dude I see that I see
maybe not as much but I see off an
atheist and [ __ ] like oh you know you
know pushing their [ __ ] on it's like who
gives a [ __ ] I never care what you
believe ever I never care what you
believe
ever ever every hour every new hour I do
I always talk about that too I can't get
away from it like like when somebody's
like oh yeah I don't if I'm like I you
know if somebody's like oh that movie
can as a matter of fact one of my
buddies the other day was like yep I
haven't seen the El Royale movie with
Chris Hemsworth and and and whatever but
my buddy's like best movie I ever seen
him one at top 10 20 who's ever seen now
my buddy who says that let uh here's the
thing if you like if you see a movie and
right away you're like one of the top 20
movies I've ever seen in my life
you're a [ __ ] CUDA that's what you are
you gotta wait and give it time to
gestate you got to say okay you know
what
like for instance Black Swan was a great
movie when I saw it I was like wow oh
Moulin Rouge is another one when I saw
him on the mergers like oh my god i sat
there in the movie theater I cried at
the end of it I cried at the end of the
movie now granted it was probably a lot
because I have a lot of my own [ __ ]
going on too because I was with my
ex-girlfriend watching it but that [ __ ]
I was like one of the best was ever seen
now when someone asked me top ten was
ever seen I never mentioned Moulin Rouge
why because it really affected me while
it was happening but now it did instead
this standing the test of time
do I still like it yeah but didn't room
there you know I mean come on top ten no
I mean will they vote cachet I said swap
but still I mean yeah a little I could
say I say squat but yeah but still do
top ten no I don't know anyway you got
it so he saw a battle what is it good
times bad times i bel Royale whatever
the El Royale Battle Royale it's like
[ __ ] and he's like dude he immediately
texted the group top 20 movies I've ever
seen
first of all who the [ __ ] says that was
in the top 20 movies I've ever seen
that's too many
no I mean top five is like the list top
10 yo dude good bad times at El Royale
top that one in my top 35 hey what the
[ __ ] are you talking about so he's
getting caught up in the moment that's
like a chick in high school that goes
and studies abroad to Italy and then
like loses her virginity in Italy
because she's caught up in the moment
that girl and this is [ __ ] of the times
you letting [ __ ] get to you stay strong
baby stay strong keep your virginity
intact when you study abroad in Italy
come back
to Delaware and [ __ ] a guy that works at
a loading dock now that's the kind of
chick that I want to be with you
understand me oh I went to [ __ ]
Prague and there was this guy and he was
so mysterious and the lighting was red
because every time Chris D'Elia thinks
of something going on in Prague
everything everything is has a red tint
in it but that's because he's [ __ ]
ignorant and has no idea what Prague is
like you know
Bulova Cosette ssy is all I'm saying
so yeah so that's what I'm saying about
the [ __ ] don't lose your virginity
anywhere but where you live dude if you
lose your virginity if you make it a big
deal you're basically like my buddy who
said good bad times at El Royale is top
20 movies of all time and you don't want
to be a guy like that you don't want to
have a top 20 movie list if you have a
top 20 movie list you're a [ __ ] dork
by the way have five also top 5 is an
annoying argument dude when everyone's
like oh yeah you like anytime someone's
like you like Tupac you like biggie you
like jay-z who are your top 500 you know
my top five favorite [ __ ] anything
art huh and those are my top five
favorite everythings and there are farts
babies top five favorite movies The
Godfather those are my top five favorite
movies greatest MCS Tupac leakin get out
of here it's an annoying argument boring
[ __ ] are like who's your top
five boring [ __ ] top five
movies mine part two and it's boring
dude stop with the top five argument top
100 and when someone next time someone
asks me what's your top five this I'm
gonna say oh I'm gonna rip them off and
then I'm gonna say what do you top 100
and then how do I know and I say I don't
know how do I know my top five that's
what dorks do see ya
and then drive away gonna have the
conversation where you're in a car
though and someone's outside of the car
if someone asks me I'm outside the car
might be like come here come here come
here what's your top five favorite
favorite MCS come here come here come
here quick come here walk with me over
here where you going all right what's
that who your top five MCS that's how we
do it do it that was being in the top
floor of a building taking the elevator
down to the garage level with the guy
and then [ __ ] getting the car and
then asking him and if you don't know
now you know if you don't know hey now
you know then we need a new cord on the
[ __ ] computer because what every time
I pick it up it goes wrong and I can't
do the [ __ ] soundboard but it's all
good baby so we don't need the
soundboard we do it how we do it yeah so
uh you know how are you New Year's
resolutions in yadda yadda and it gives
a [ __ ] but it's all don't have any
resolutions just be purse it's free
conch have one if you want but if you do
just realize in the next week you gonna
turn round yeah what's up with people
also still say and I had a buddy that
that was like what do you call it that
was like whoops is that you that mean
when people uh when people are like hey
need to how about this its 2018 anytime
anybody texts you any sort of hey dude
when can you have a conversation hey
dude I love to talk about some [ __ ] hey
it's a long thing can I can we phone
call it no dude
abso-fucking-lutely not no hey dude it's
too long to text
do you know what it isn't do you know
why there are books out there that are
1000 pages be an r and in this
[ __ ] if there's an R and out
there if John Grisham exists texting if
Michael Crichton is writin then text it
it's too long a text no it's not you can
do it in three sentences also what's it
about at least give me that much I've
got to talk to you about some cool
what's it about
that's better on the phone click go to
info delete contact block see ya
you made your bed line it I'm inside you
dude what the [ __ ] no no no and I mean
it you don't text me [ __ ] like that you
don't do that you don't text me let me
call you no no no no you you text the
whole thing or at least what it's about
do you know why cuz Michael Crichton's
writin because John Christians out there
now [ __ ] there's autobiographies there's
there's fictional I mean one fires
texted me Crichton is dead I know he's
dead but Crichton is writing is a real
good thing to say okay I can't say
Crichton is right it Saddam
Crichton wrote Crichton wrote one fire
one might makes me want to take the
humor at it out of it so I can say
Crichton wrote even though Crichton
write and I'll get a laugh this is the
thing I'm doing from now on I'm going
and then cuz I got fire ago I do that do
it I don't give a [ __ ] I do it at the
coffee bean and I don't give a [ __ ] and
I'm cool you know what bryan callen
texted me the other day and he was he
said he saw you he ran in he met a girl
and she said yeah I saw Chris at the
coffee bean
and you said I'll what was he doing he
said looking at his phone and he said
was he doing it for a while and she said
yeah and I was do it you think I give a
[ __ ] dude I was reading articles
probably and I was also on Instagram but
it doesn't matter dude
it doesn't matter man I [ __ ] sit and
I enjoy life one time I i heard that
quote that John Lennon said about how if
you're enjoying life or whatever it is
you're not wasting time at all it
doesn't matter what you're doing dude
that's the [ __ ] I took that to heart and
now I do that and I don't feel like I
waste time I used to be upset I used to
be upset that I was sleeping in and now
I don't do it it's part of life baby why
would you feel bad if you feel good
that's the craziest [ __ ]
I understand struggle and I understand
getting out of your comfort zone is
absolutely something that is needed for
growth and it makes you a better person
quote unquote I get that but if you do
some of that why would you feel bad
about sleeping in why would you feel bad
about jerking off why would you feel bad
about eating some doughnuts
dude do it man why would you feel bad
about wasting time laughing with your
friends and not getting worked on if you
got it you got it don't if you're having
a good time don't feel bad that what the
[ __ ] dude that's the [ __ ] that's the
[ __ ] life's about coming laughing and
eating sweets that's what it's about
and if you don't want to eat sweets eat
a nice [ __ ] two in a bowl you don't
wanna get cancer eat a little bit of
sweets or the need of two in a bowl but
have a good time dude people feel bad oh
no I got to get work done no you know
what I got it why dude you don't you'll
get it done you know what dude I used to
when I when I would have to get like
even now when I have to get real [ __ ]
done something I used to be like have it
stress me out and be like oh I got to
get it done I got to get it done it's
not stressing me out cuz it's not done
I'd put myself at the at the end of the
task like I'd in my head I'd be like
okay like say I got to get something
done by Tuesday Monday I got to do it I
got to do it either Saturday Sunday
Monday or whatever I would get to the
point where I would be
I'm so stressed out I didn't do it yet
it's almost gonna be Monday night I'm
gonna be cramming I would put myself
mentally at Tuesday and I would be like
hey guess what it's going to get done
it's going to be done there's nothing I
can do about it because I have to do it
so therefore it's practically Tuesday
because it's gonna be done it's gonna be
done it's gonna be Tuesday soon and I'm
gonna be done I put myself there stress
gone Tony Robbins hey Tony Robbins go
jump in your [ __ ] cold pool I got
this from here hey Tony Robbins go take
a dip in your cold pool and then hop oh
and then go back to your cold pool I got
this from here it's gonna be done why
you stressed out what's gonna happen is
gonna happen you make it not an option
anyway you got to do it right I don't
want to work out today I'm gonna do it
gotta therefore it's done do you
understand yeah you understand you
understand I saw a [ __ ] you know what
makes me always feel really [ __ ] good
I see when I see like moms out there
with like carrying three bags and a baby
and like another little toddler behind
them I'm always like dude you go you go
mom that [ __ ] makes me feel good it
makes me feel like shout out to all
those moms out there for real like
that's hard [ __ ] work and I know this
is 2018 and we realize how hard work
that is now it's not like the 50s
anymore we're like yeah the wife doesn't
have a job I'm always [ __ ] slaving
away and this [ __ ] Dame with her gams
it's just cooking in the kitchen that's
all she gets to do she gets to relax
with the kids you know I know 2018 and
we all realize that now but still that
[ __ ] is awesome it's bonkers when you
see a mom walking
to Trader Joe's with four bags and
[ __ ] two kids uh get get out of here
that's amazing shout out to those [ __ ]
moms for real and if you're a mom and
you listen to this podcast which I don't
know this is that demo but shout out to
you man and if you're listening to it
with your kids you're a bad mom but
you're a good mom because you know what
life is like and you understand maybe
it's too young for a four-year-old to
listen to this but also thank you thank
you for the revenue yeah I always I saw
one and I just like was staring at her
like a creep I realized oh [ __ ] I'm
staring at her like a creep but I'm like
actually staring at her because like I
admire her
but anyway talk man it's uh it's uh it
is what it is but yeah just text your
[ __ ] whole thing if you're about to
call somebody and say all that I need to
you know talk to you about this thing or
I need to give you the rundown just text
the whole rundown rundown
I'd like to all let's do ads yeah I'd
like to do ads and then I want to talk
about this past weekend me undies
oh dude let me tell you something me
undies sent me a bunch of pair underwear
it's awesome you can go on my Instagram
story right now I posted all of the
things I [ __ ] folded them nicely and
[ __ ] it looks awesome they sent me a
bunch of underwear it's all color-coded
and [ __ ] man I feel so good in these
neon these Valentine's Day is right
around the corner rather than spending
all that money going out to fancy
restaurants why not just hanging your
underwear all night courtesy of me
undies dude don't go out and spend
thousands of dollars on Valentines
put on your coveted micro Motel fabric
which is three times softer than cotton
that me undies makes this fabric
genuinely feels like actual heaven
against your skin
I don't know it cuz I've never been to
heaven but I have it on right now feels
like how I think heaven would be you can
also get a style that is perfectly
suited for you you can get so many
different patterns men and women can
each choose from four different cuts all
of which are available from classic
colors too adventurous prints
my favorite ones right now are just the
all single color ones like I have the
gray one on now but I have ones with
bananas on them I have ones with hearts
on them I have ones with polar bears on
them I mean dude they have it all they
really do
speaking of prints this vide a season me
undies will be releasing a new print
every Tuesday so that's very cool you
and your loved one can chillin matching
matching prints for v-day and play a
game of how long can we keep these on if
you know what I mean all sound of the
bed my undies has a great offer for my
listeners for any first-time purchasers
when you order me undies you get 15% off
and free shipping this is a no brainer
come on man are you romantic then get
these get 15% off a pair of the most
comfortable undies you will ever put on
to keep your 50% off your first pair
free shipping and a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee you go to me
undies dot-com / Congrats that's me
andis calm / Congrats won't eat on
that's the sound of the bed cash app you
already know the cash app is the number
one app in finance but did you realize
you can get the most powerful debit card
with two in the world with the cash apps
cash card the cash card comes with
boosts a feature you can't get anywhere
else because cash app invented it Doyle
yo you just select a boost in your cash
app swipe the cash card and save 10% or
more at Whole Foods Shake Shack Chipotle
Taco Bell chick-fil-a and all coffee
shops around the country the coffee shop
boost takes $1 off at any coffee shop
including Dunkin and Starbucks drink 100
cups a year save what you're bad at math
let me help you out hundred dollars it's
that simple
become a part of the greatest rewards
program ever and download the cash app
now it's the number one app for a reason
and the cash card is the only debit card
with boosts and of course when you
download the cash app and enter the
referral code congrats you receive $5
and the cash app will send $5 to the
times up Legal Defense Fund
visit the App Store or Google Play
market and download the cash app I watch
that show you know what I like on
honestly I like the limited runs of the
shows I like shows that are on for two
or three seasons
I like shows that are on for one season
you know why cuz that's all everyone
really making a show knows what the [ __ ]
they're going to do by you know what I'm
talking about any time you're doing like
a [ __ ] show and the last for like 11
seasons like the guys the people in
Grey's Anatomy right now the people that
house when it was on its 42nd season
this was these were the producers every
day I don't know
we could have guys get hit by trucks and
then come in and have the doctor work on
them and then they're guys like all
right and then they just write it the
[ __ ] hey man I want you to think about
it more I sort of god that's what these
shows to even Game of Thrones is doing
it right now that guy what's his name
Jared Tolkien oh no that's not that's
the Lord of the Rings whoever that
[ __ ] dork is George Martin hey George
Martin you're a [ __ ] billionaire but
let's not forget hey dark okay they
don't know what they're doing he knew
what he was doing he wrote the whole
things but now the producers a game of
Thrones dude they're like this the
Dragons can breathe fire on the town and
the guys have down their friends but
they could become enemies now and
there's a slice in heads and then the
other participants like this okay okay
and then the guy Sergius comes in and
then Salinas comes in and then JB astiz
comes flying on a dragon and put his
fire on the town and then the guy goes
like this okay and then go like this
right it this is okay and it goes off
and he writes us and he write it and he
writes it and you watch it you're
basically just that's what this podcast
is by the way that's what this podcast
is and you don't think it's Game of
Thrones you pieces of [ __ ]
you understand me you think this pot
gave you like yeah and I just like to
listen and I just [ __ ] winging it and
having a good time he thinks of a few
[ __ ] things
that's what Game of Thrones is that's
what Grey's Anatomy is okay so what I'm
basically saying is give me 20 Emmys I'm
doing what they're doing the first few
seasons yeah they got it down they think
hard they gotta come up with the pitch
they got to talk to the network they
gotta be like and this was gonna happen
in the second season maybe in the third
season we got this thing has legs she's
got legs so sexist that song surprise
easy top it was it by anyway it doesn't
matter what matters is give me a [ __ ]
group of Emmys in Linnton tenant and
tenant and tenant and tenant naynay in
the thing and I'll in any such a theme
song and they don't know what the [ __ ]
they're doing at this point have the
Dragons just [ __ ] and then breathe fire
and then guy goes like this okay and
then Sergius does the think I put xerxis
in it hello we're all the trigons but
xerxis was in 300 I don't care was he a
real character in history who gives a
[ __ ] hello give me my dragons yeah I
rented and think written and then
Renison beat random youtube what was I
gonna do YouTube that's so sexist that
song she's got legs yeah I mean she's
got legs you know what I mean it
basically could just what listen this by
ZZ Top of course it is how you know it's
sexist Chris Chris kid Chris Chris Rock
[ __ ] covered it
this is sexist the first of all the most
manly music video of all time started
she's walking close-up of a girl in
heels walking then close-up of
motorcycles driving and then a guy stops
and they're in a burger shop or some
[ __ ] when he's serving burgers and is
the worst music now without the
beginning at the wart you got a look at
this easy top beginning is easy top
she's got legs there's a worse beginning
of any mmm music video I've ever seen in
my life which makes it the best I think
actually you know what it is it's so
[ __ ] the French wave of cinema and
like the 70 he says by the way why would
you say sorry you just the guy who said
the guy who says you got something over
here guess if he's were on a [ __ ]
sleeveless jean jacket ah okay now
listen to this song just listen to this
oh and then the Ben just appears out of
nowhere
[Music]
oh my god
serving or giving her a burger and she's
just got a dress on like a diamond dress
sexy he's got like a skirt on and she's
got legs she knows how to use them
[Music]
oh she's got legs she knows how they
should basically make this song called
she's got tits you know just as sexist
only we don't you know real Isaac so
sang legs she's got tits she knows how
to use them
[ __ ] today is bouncing around
Paranal right now and by the way in the
80s that [ __ ] would've rocked nobody
would have been like even chicks would
have been like [ __ ] yeah I do have
titties and know how to use them but now
it's not okay
I'm surprised that song isn't banned but
they probably don't play it on radio
stations because right now because of
that because of the whole [ __ ] baby
it's cold outside
that [ __ ] was great baby it's cold
outside
Lam Arabia you know that's what they
thought it was basically baby it's cold
outside
ah I'm Bill Cosby I don't know dude
whatevs whatevs dude whatever whatever's
clever you know when people say that
pokers in your eyes when you say it uh
yeah dude you ever have pain in your
[ __ ] like for no reason I have pain
in my hand and it and I think about it
now all the all day and it's annoying as
[ __ ] for zero reason I woke up just all
of a sudden pain in my hand and it's
gonna be like that for a [ __ ] week
man when you get older it sucks I mean
I'm I'm just I'm really young I'm
[ __ ] so young on I'm 38 so I'm like
still like my testosterone is building
I'm still very very virile you know I
haven't hit my sexual prime yet you know
I'm just I barely went through [ __ ]
puberty
I'm just Verrill I'm 38 you know what I
mean I'm not I'm by no means 45
so yeah you wake up and things start
[ __ ] bustin down you wake up all of a
sudden guess what your shoulder hurts
you wake up all of a sudden guess what
you got any props you showed you guys
sure your shoulder hurts and you got any
props and it's because you're 38 and
that's it
taking cyanide one fire just took a pill
cyanide
ending his life done so yeah I folded my
underwear on the [ __ ] I mean dude my
girls making me watch that [ __ ]
tidying up [ __ ] that thing on
Netflix
Oh get out okay all right cool oh you
can tidy up snot a biz oh you can you
can tidy up hey Marie canto snot a biz
oh you can hire her to come have you
seen it it's on Netflix called tidying
up she comes in and she's like okay is
she what is she
what's her net Japanese dude she comes
in by the way it needs a translator
which is fine but she's always like okay
you get and they just dump [ __ ] out get
rid of all this [ __ ] that's what she
does okay
snot a biz and guess what it's not a TV
show either it's it's it's straight-up
bad okay now no knock no knock on the
show I know I said it's bad I'm [ __ ]
half joking i watch it and [ __ ] but this
whole face what you know what it is it's
the new march of the Penguins that's
what it is you made me watch march of
the Penguins
and march of the Penguins you know what
it was penguins dick in round just shots
of penguins [ __ ] each other and
walking and waiting and traveling
together and Morgan Freeman talking all
over it I don't give a [ __ ] about that
I got things to think of I got a [ __ ]
tralala going on in my head I got to sit
and watch pictures of penguins or cold
and [ __ ] and Morgan Freeman's like the
Penguins are monotonous I don't give a
[ __ ] I've never seen a goddamn penguin
the [ __ ] do I have to watch it on TV for
so this Mary Conte oh by the way how is
that her last name
oh she must have married a [ __ ] condo
it's short for condominium Mary
condominium Mary condom Mary lubricated
condom so not funny and so juvenile that
was the worst joke I've ever made in on
this whole podcast it's a hundred three
episodes in anyway Mary condo does the
[ __ ] tidying up [ __ ] and she comes in
and she's just like okay get rid of
clothing and get rid of all this
[ __ ] thank this for being in your
life and then oh wait what how a oh I'm
sorry I stopped there what'd you say you
have to thank this for B you have to
think this for being in your life and
then get rid of it
oh it's a vest hey you know what I've
never done talked to socks okay oh but
the saw
so tired and you have to know they're
not tired know why they don't have
brains okay
so there's a way to fold underwear I
folded all the underwear there's a way
to fold socks did it okay got it fine uh
she my favorite one was but it's just
annoying how everyone's like you're
watching tidying up you're watching it
yeah okay it's fine it's exactly what
how boring and good you'd think it would
be this [ __ ] little Japanese lady
comes in and says throw [ __ ] away and
they throw it away and then the before
and after pictures look roughly the same
it'd be one thing to if she was helping
people in mansions and [ __ ] so you could
see a real difference she's helping
people in like two bedroom apartments
which is like so they throw away a few
[ __ ] sweatshirts and some pots and
pans get put away in a [ __ ] lower
cabinet and then they're like she's
changed my life we have sex three times
more a week now thank you marry
condominium thank you
there was one with a the best was she
comes in and she [ __ ] she I would
like to start by greeting at the house
Hey very Kondo did you know a house is a
house and it isn't a family did you know
the house isn't [ __ ] Border Patrol
Hey
this is house this is a house not a
[ __ ] cocktail party so she walks in
she greets the house she gets on the
knees that's the best one with the black
family dude they get in she greets the
house she sits on the [ __ ] on her
knees and she puts her palms backwards
for some reason and puts him on the
ground and she sits there and closes her
eyes while she greets the house now do
whatever you want I by the way
love her love how passionate she is
about to clean it's the [ __ ] dude I
listen to part of our audiobook and the
how passionate she is about [ __ ]
tidying up is absolutely awesome it's
awesome
this lady is awesome she really is
awesome I love that there's enough
[ __ ] actors and actresses and [ __ ]
out there
this lady is so passionate about tidying
up she's this [ __ ] dude
she really is this Marie Kondo girl is
awesome but the show is just like
alright so she's tidying up I don't get
it so she greets the house and the the
best was there's this there's this black
family I was like this really sweet
family and I just love when they when
she greets the house and the black
family is like so into it but it's so
like it's so basically it what's so
Japanese the whole thing but it's also
so something that like white people
would be like this is really the new
thing this is it we greet the house we
thank our socks and we say good morning
to our [ __ ] ball caps and our pots
and pans we use them and we love we
actually love them that's such a like
white thing to adopt from it from
Japanese culture and for it to become a
fad for a year and then forget about it
right okay but and black people don't do
that [ __ ] and it's so funny that the
black family is there and she's greeting
the house and even though they seem all
into it I like to imagine that there's
like this the the the uncle that they
don't show like yeah alright you know he
he lives in like the [ __ ] side room
and but they're like yeah you could do a
show it is tidying up [ __ ] but you
know I ain't don't feel me I got my own
space I ain't tidy and [ __ ] up so if
they still want to do it then they want
to do it and then that he's just like
behind the camera crew like in the
corner just like watching and she's like
so it's time to greet the house and he's
just like and and ever end there and the
and the family's just like this and the
kids are like this and the the black dad
who's back practically white is just
sitting there like this and the lady is
like the black lady sitting there like
this and then
like the uncle that stays with him
that's like the guy that just and he's
just like okay look um and they cut all
these parts out but he's just saying if
she's gonna thank the house okay
oh she going oh I don't know um what
y'all just to say like you know I
noticed this show and we're gonna do
[ __ ] for the show but speech is thinking
this [ __ ] is greeting the house yo I'm
like it's all good you know I don't want
to say nothing but just be thinking I
know you're doing your show but can I
talk to you for a second Charles come
over here we got we got [ __ ] in here
Corey analysis you understand what I'm
saying and you were acting just for the
cameras I get it but you need to tell me
right now are you with this [ __ ] green
in the house or do you understand what
this [ __ ] doing is some Japanese [ __ ]
and these why people gonna take it and
run with it
but you [ __ ] you understand we
don't do this [ __ ] oh we thank your
socks now you know he's in the bags we
thank each underwear
we thank the shirts we should we think
these are jeans you don't need that
anymore and then the end then the uncle
who is in the side room just like this
eating a bowl eating the [ __ ] popcorn
just like looking just like this [ __ ]
thanking the pair of jeans
this [ __ ] taking a pair of jeans oh I
ain't even trying to interrupt but like
they cut this part out okay uh let me
just get in here I'm sorry so sorry crew
remember let me grab the this is these
are my jeans I don't know how they got
mixed up with Charles's geniuses but I'm
gonna take these jeans I don't want you
talking to my excuse me thank you excuse
me
thank you Mary I uh these these my jeans
I don't want you even talking to my
jeans like they real people these are my
jeans okay I'm gonna take this I'm gonna
put in my corner that I do not want you
to touch now I gotta run a Rite Aid and
I gotta grab some [ __ ] and and guess
what I might grab some [ __ ] I don't even
need but I'm gonna keep it in my [ __ ]
in my room right here and you ain't gon
goin
here okay yeah I got extra [ __ ] like
there's a bottle opener right here it's
in my bedroom
why the [ __ ] a bottle opener in my broom
I don't guess well I don't know if I was
crazy you probably asked his
[ __ ] it's a goddamn bottle
opener you're gonna ask his bottle over
a bar
hey this is if I was you hey what's up
why are you in his bedroom oh I don't
know I'm a [ __ ] bottle opener how
about that meri condominium what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you
I'm gonna keep this bottle opener next
to my bed in case I wanna [ __ ] look
empty bottles right here right here at
the foot of my bed right here we ain't
getting rid of it that's what we doing
we're keeping it right there I used the
goddamn bottle open to open that [ __ ]
and I got a beer right here that's warm
as [ __ ] I'm gonna keep it here I'm gonna
fridge in here and if I take it and put
it in a goddamn fridge you ain't gonna
get rid of it and if you do you ain't
gonna thank it cuz this my [ __ ] yeah I
ain't gonna do you Japanese white people
[ __ ] over here and they cut that part
out and they film crews just like just
let him let him go let him go let him go
and then there's a black filmmaker he's
like and you know what the [ __ ] this is
man you know what the [ __ ] these
[ __ ] doing I know you got a job
to do and you holding the camera but you
know this [ __ ] is crazy
thanking these jeans give me my [ __ ]
jeans these are mine give me the belt
that's mine too with the jeans give it
give it to me
don't talk to my belt don't go in my
[ __ ] room I'm keeping it [ __ ] this
[ __ ] a mess these [ __ ] walking
out [ __ ] green asses [ __ ]
[ __ ] may account Oh [ __ ] up my life
and he's in his bedroom just by himself
I can tell [ __ ] on my life man
brainwashing these [ __ ] I
remember when we used to [ __ ] just
save bottle caps man we used to save
stamps to get rid of that [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] my purpose shorts go I
like not being able to find [ __ ] tidy up
my tidy up my ass dog there's my mess in
this [ __ ] all right let's do uh
but I'll man so funny to think she
actually thanking that she greet in the
house this already she knew this was a
bad idea
um all right we're gonna you know we're
gonna do an elder it's been a while it's
been a while month um - no no no no is
that stained it's been a while right it
is stained is the most number I said
fuel is the most ninety song no stained
is the most ninety song I mean right
stained is the most spin a while this
music will be out of fashion once 2000
hits it's been wrong oh I mean he's got
the bald white guy with the guitar or
smoking a cigarette with the [ __ ]
tribal tattoos ha candles in the video
just candles like it's a seance Wow and
a [ __ ] eyebrow ring could it be more
90s only more 90s if he was on a [ __ ]
razor scooter while he was doing it and
[ __ ] George Hamilton was in the video
to her whose real 90s dan Cortese his
80s right no he's 90s alright so here's
an elder we got a new elder here and
because we got to build this log cabin
crew man we have to build this log cabin
crew and it had you know we started
giving people eldership and you know and
making them elders of the of the of the
cult and there's a few out there a lot
of you guys do good work you spread the
word but we got to make this person an
elder and I'm not sure if it's one or
two of you guys I think it's just one
but you guys over the past year have
done so much for getting the world
word out there and helping and it's the
guys or guy at bleach media official on
Instagram and it's so funny
the [ __ ] that they do and it's Andrew
Baxter his name is aka Andrew Baxter
didn't put the ER at the end it's an a
instead change it but maybe it already
was taken so Andrew Baxter you're an
elder you don't have to change it but
you just congratulations man you're an
elder I think it's only you if it's two
guys we'll send two pins but you got to
let me know we'll be in touch
but you guys kill it man if you're not
following them follow them and also
follow me on Instagram I repost their
stuff and they also do stuff with other
podcasts too which is just really funny
they do I don't know how they have the
[ __ ] time the guy must have like the
most boringest job but he's Annette I
know he's met her I met him once at the
coffee bean once he was he was there
he's like I'm the guy I'm from bleach
meeting I'm like oh [ __ ]
so uh anyway he kills it do it thank you
and you're an older now so we're sending
you [ __ ] we sent you a baby's hoodie but
we're gonna send you an elder and the
gifts and a certificate of
authentication of authentic ization of
about how you know elder so thank you
bleach media um yeah so that's good now
let's do some misconnections or what
these misconnections are a big hit here
we used to do most [ __ ] up Instagram
post of the week and we'll there hasn't
i'm forgotten about that every now and
then i come across with some [ __ ] but
you know i do stuff and then i get it
poppin and then i leave it that's what
happens man you said it and then you
forget you said it and you forget it i'm
ron popeil in this [ __ ] I'm around
Papale in this [ __ ] okay I said it and
I forget it I don't [ __ ] dwell on it I
don't roll with the [ __ ] you know this
is here we're here we got a Miskin miss
connection right here it's called relax
that's the title relax
Wow black guy available now for any guys
that wants a nude rub that's the guy
by the way that's the fifth guy that
lives with that black family and uh
tidying up all right you know I'm gonna
do straight up because you're [ __ ]
around with this tidying up I'm gonna
invite i'ma go on Craigslist and I'ma
i'ma tell people I'm down for if anybody
wants a new rub if anybody wants a new
rub that's gonna be me and they're gonna
come in my space and angle be [ __ ]
greeting houses and [ __ ] you know I'm
talkin about
they gonna be thanking no pairs of you
I'm gonna take their [ __ ] pants
off and I'm gonna do a nude rub with
them I'm gonna take their [ __ ] shirts
and they sacks off an angle [ __ ]
thank they socks and gonna thank they
jeans and [ __ ] that we're gonna put in a
pile and then if they leave some of
their [ __ ] here guess what's happening
it's gonna stay here it ain't we ain't
getting rid of that [ __ ] we
keeping it here because this is my
section of the house goddamn it and if
that [ __ ] [ __ ] marry condo come
around and she like you really need this
I'm gonna be like [ __ ] you I really need
this it reminds me of the time I'll rub
that [ __ ] down with that dude here we go
another another this one starts off
flyer by the way this miss connection
starts off fire I unclog pipe and offer
stress relief unload robots I unclog
pipe I unclog pipe and offer a stress
relief unload and offer Straus really
fun load I unclog pipe and offer stress
relief unload codeword for sex code for
horizontal mambo e on e all that's the
sound of the bed unit on Trini all just
like I'm offering here's the body I'm
offering oral service to I mean dude
this couldn't be more off dude the least
sexy thing and which makes it the most
sexy because everything's a full circle
but is it's to say offer I offer you
there
go I am offering a little service to
give your pipe stress release relief
come get drained average big thick
stocky husky football player build men
sand your stats height weight location
picks tree to tree four two zero six oh
that's the [ __ ] phone number tree to
tree code for the number hey man we know
it's three two three I'm offering oral
service heck to give your pipe stress
release relief Oh sadand end
would you like release relief I'm
offering oral service to give your pipe
stress release relief and then right
down to it in case there was any doubt
come get drained heck come get drained
soft color had a hey dude
here's something for sure you had a bad
childhood you're writing come get
drained on the Internet
average big thick stocky husky football
player build men why can none of these
guys do the right tense or spelling
right send your stats height weight
location pics I unclog so anyway if
there's anybody anyway if there's
anybody out there that wants their pipe
unclogged wink and all and need some
stress relief unload wink higher this
robot he's in the LA area near Alhambra
do not contact him though with
unsolicited services or offers Wow what
time we had here here's another one
here's another one I here we go
Margeaux moving over the lights in the
way Margo I find myself very attracted
to you
I told you I loved your eyes you told me
you had cataract ah worst romance novel
writer of all time
Margo I find myself very attracted to
you I told you I loved you I told you I
loved your eyes and you told me you had
cataract well we do would it be so hard
to write the word uh before cataract I
had a you had it kind of also not sexy
oh my god baby I love your cataracts I
am nervous to make a move not sure you
would react positively what's with this
[ __ ] robots dude if you ever read
this and would like to know more next
time you see me even though you can't
really see well because you got
cataracts let me know Margo I find
that's the best right there that's the
best beginning of anyone that we've ever
had
Margo I find myself very attracted to
you I told you I loved your eyes you
told me you had cataract I also imagine
just being in that situation there wow I
love your eyes oh thanks I have
cataracts I mean and then the guy still
likes the person if I said to somebody
enough I thought they were like there
was something interesting about him and
that they were hot and I was like oh I
want to I want to say oh god you know
what your beautiful eyes and then the
quote-unquote hot Margo chick says or
Thanks you know I have cataracts I go
like this I go
please I got beautiful eyes ya have
cataracts okay
anyway catch you later pivot she's got
she's got cataracts she talks about him
too early in the conversation I just
said I liked her she said by the way hey
man how about this she's trying to get
rid of you hey dude just firing this
misconnection out there if you're out
there and you want to talk more what
what girl likes a guy what girl
right away mentions a [ __ ]
shortcoming if she likes a guy she
doesn't like you dude oh yeah beautiful
you have beautiful eyes I mean she was
so trying to shut him down
oh well you have beautiful eyes I have
cataracts Thanks oh I'll hit her up on
Craigslist
[ __ ] I have cataracts that's it
dude I mean right
what will wrap up babies you guys okay
you guys killed it this episode you see
you audience thank you so download the
cash app for free on the App Store or
Google Market and two rewards code
congrats five dollars give five dollars
you get five dollars and give five
dollars and times up but listen I'm
gonna be in Colorado Springs I'm gonna
be in I mean here's another one watch me
blow any guys or girls want to watch
blow my load on skype or facetime let's
have some fun
ASAP I like how there's a time limit on
it I gotta go to work but if you want to
watch me blow let's do this here's my
Skype wanna watch me come here's my
Skype wanna watch me blow here's my
Skype all right cool sorry to st. Louis
I had to reschedule the new one is
February 24th so your tickets are valid
still for that I heard only 30 people
had to get their money back cuz they
can't go so that makes me very happy I'm
sorry to you 30 but so now there's
tickets available because I had to
reschedule
on the 24th right yeah st. Louis seen
those will be the 24th but also uh
Boulder Colorado those are sold out
Colorado Springs are still some tickets
left Madison Milwaukee Chicago sold out
Seattle Hamilton Ontario Windsor Ontario
Kalamazoo Anaheim San Ynez anyway
go to the website crystal a calm and
that's what's up
download the crystal Lea app you see
that you'll see the podcast and hear it
before anybody and we see those babies
hoodies out there looking good those are
my favorites right now so go get those
there's some left
we're restocking the Dan Swan but you
can go get some baby hoodie baby cities
and other merch
go check it out subscribe to the YouTube
channel please we want more subscribers
if you watch the videos on YouTube it
will be very cool to also subscribe to
my channel thanks it helps me back up
the Brinks truck video pod does it'll go
out every Tuesday and if they're better
too they're good to watch I guess you
know some people like I'm so [ __ ]
good on there
and also watch my episode of comedians
of the world on Netflix it's comedians
in the world go in there
click comedians of the world I'm episode
2 and watch everybody else my episode is
called non-stop it's a special on
Netflix and thanks a lot and and
congratulations to Chris Pratt getting
engaged you guys thanks a lot guys
[Music]